le mois dernier david sainson à planter
près de 1000 arbres sur les bords de son
exploitation d essence de noisetiers des
piles blanches et noires qui dans
quelques années formeront des corridors
écologiques
ça va permettre de ré installer
notamment des insectes qui vont un
devenir des auxiliaires pour la culture
et puis deux qui vont servir aussi
alimenter toute une faune notamment des
oiseaux on coupe un peu nos parcelles
donc ça permet un peu figé ce découpage
de parcelles et puis ça permet de
redonner un peu de vie et cette plaine
qui était vraiment des new delhi vers de
véritables atouts pour cet agriculteur
grâce à leurs racines qui stocke l'eau
en cas de fortes pluies
les permettent d'augmenter la
rentabilité d'une parcelle
pourtant elles ont longtemps été
considéré comme un obstacle à
l'agriculture entre 1950 et aujourd'hui
75% de et ont été abattus en france
suite notamment à la guerre à
l'évolution de l'agriculture et c'est
rare et culture s'est transformé les
parcelles se sont agrandies et de ce
fait il ya eu arrachage de et de façon
extrêmement importante des arrachages
qui perdure selon cet exploitant pour
lui l'objectif affiché par le
gouvernement de plantes et 7000 km de
haies en deux ans reste insuffisant il
ya une action très forte abonnés pour le
maintien de ce qui existe à dire que si
on ferme les yeux sur la destruction et
qu'en même temps on construit à côté
bon ça au final le bilan sera une
opération au mieux blanche un dispositif
financé à 80% par l'état pour aider les
agriculteurs dans l'indre les opérations
de plantation reprendront dans quelques
semaines